bresse le sujet de ce journal c'est
l'arménie et les arméniens 67 ans après
après un génocide que la diaspora
arménienne commémore aujourd'hui alors
d'abord le plus simple didier regnier
c'est de suivre votre résumé historique
m
attentif il battra alors que les filles
aient fait attraper par les plus grands
notre reine sofia 3 3 7e embauché aussi
qui qu'elle ait kaci si l'on aurait
offert 100 euros pour avoir l'occasion
de notre peau si le mans
immo
ce soir là au palais de la mutualité il
y avait bien sûr ceux pour qui la
violence représente l'unique solution au
problème arménien mais il y avait
surtout trois générations réunies dans
une même salle
malgré leurs différences trois
générations qui se souviennent 67 ans
après et qui exprime tankers le réveil
arménien trois générations qui refusent
d'oublier l'histoire leur histoire
à la fin du 19e siècle le réveil de la
conscience nationale avait amené les
arméniens située en territoire turc a
exigé des réformes le reconnaissant plus
de libertés démocratiques et plus de
droits par l'article 16 du traité de
berlin
la sublime porte s'engageait à réaliser
les réformes nécessaires dans les
provinces arméniennes
mais cet article ne sera jamais
appliquée
les intellectuels gronde les paysans se
révoltent le sultan abdülhamid réprime
un plan de réforme pour l'arménie est
imposé par les puissances occidentales
mais le commencement de la première
guerre mondiale en empêche l'application
le drame arménien commence à l'aube du
samedi 24 avril 1915 date à laquelle le
gouvernement jeune turc fait arrêter par
surprise tous les intellectuels de
constantinople 600 personnes sont exilés
à l'intérieur de l'anatolie
elles ne reviendront jamais commence
alors pour les arméniens un véritable
cauchemar
mille fois répété selon le même scénario
les hommes valides
incorporé dans l'armée avaient été
désarmées dès le mois de février se
voyant ainsi privé de tout moyen de
résistance
tous les autres arméniens capable selon
l'expression utilisée de porter les
hommes c'est à dire ceux âgés de 15 à 70
ans furent conduits en dehors des villes
dès la première vallées isolées les
gendarmes aidés par les turcs les
massacrer à coups de sabre à coups de
couteau à coups de fusil
en feu on a visé les femmes les
vieillards et les enfants qu'il serait
déportée dans un certain délai ne
dépassant en aucun cas
quinze jours les scènes de déportation
marqueront avis les rares rescapés
de trébizonde d'erzeroum de zaytoun ou
d'alep parts des convois impressionnant
de femmes et d'enfants affamés aille aux
pieds nus ou entassés sur des charrettes
il abandonne tout sur place et partent
pour le voyage sans retour dans
l'angoissé la peur des attaques tueur
ils marcheront des jours et des jours
sous la pluie sous le soleil brûlant ou
dans le froid femmes vieillards enfants
une progression hallucinante ponctué
quotidiennement de véritable cauchemar à
chaque coin de route et de forêts à
chaque halte
des témoins ont raconté les mêmes scènes
d'horreur
les femmes abandonnant leurs enfants sur
les routes
celle qui a couché sur la voie publique
battu à mort par les turcs
les femmes enceintes sont éventrés à
coups de poignard en pariant sur le sexe
de leur foetus
les centaines de cadavres flottant sur
l'euphrate
les enfants qui ont jeté sur les rochers
en leur fracassant le crâne ou en leur
écartement les membres
les femmes qu'on violait ont transpercé
à coups de baïonnette qu'on égorgeait
par centaines les prêtres conférer les
bastonnades
les enfants qu'on voyait les hangars où
étaient parqués les arméniens qui ont
incendié
pourtant leur calvaire n'était pas fini
lentement ces caravanes de posséder de
fantômes étaient dirigés vers les
déserts brûlants à cette année cinquante
mille arméniens furent emportés par la
mort mais la majeure partie des
arméniens se trouve a réuni en
mésopotamie entre alep et souligner et
deir ezzor
c'est là que le gouverneur et qui bay en
fit encore égorgé plus de 200000 les
déportés aux abois devenu fou victimes
d'une famine artificiellement créée se
mirent à vendre leurs enfants et à
manger les cadavres humains des milliers
de déportés moururent la voilà pourquoi
deir el zor reste à jamais gravé dans la
mémoire des arméniens
très peu survécurent à ce génocide qui
fit plus d'un million de victimes les
jeunes filles enlevées par les turcs sur
enfermés dans des arènes les jeunes
enfants furent enlevés par les derviches
ou vendus aux paysans la chance et le
hasard firent le reste crucifiant et
dispersant la communauté arménienne
aujourd'hui les rescapés qui ont vu et
entendu n'ont pas oublié ils sont âgés
mais leur mémoire n'a rien trail de leur
histoire on était à deir ezzor au coeur
du désert et il n'y avait pas d'eau
combien de jours avez vous marchez au je
ne sais pas exactement
il devait nous emmener à mon seul alors
ils nous ont fait tourner dans le désert
et nous en jambes dont un grand nombre
de cadavres
c'était affreux certains avaient un bras
d'un côté un corps sans tête de l'autre
tous éparpillés
vous savez ces gens là n'ont jamais eu
de cimetière
ils nous faisaient tourner pour nous
empêcher de voir l'eau on évitait les
points d'eau ni eau ni herbe
on était dans le désert et le matin tout
recommencer alors il nous disait debout
est en marche
je ne peux pas vous dire combien de
filles ont été violées les femmes
enceintes ont été éventrées
il leur retirait les foetus d'une vente
mais que vous racontez il y en a
tellement raconté
et je pense que les français doivent
connaître cela dit nous dans ce désert
de deir el zor
combien y avait-il de cadavres
des milliers alors comment expliquer ces
massages aux je ne sais pas il faudrait
des roms entier pour tenter d'expliquer
c'est impossible autrement
vous savez quand on est parti pour des
races d'or on était cinquante mille
arméniens de ma province
il n'en est pas arrivée dix mille à
mossoul
tout le reste a été massacrée ils sont
tous morts 67 ans après vous pleurez
encore comment voulez-vous faire
autrement en 1915 madame pas notion
était une enfant comme des milliers
d'autres arméniens
elle n'avait demandé qu'à vivre sur sa
terre natale